[Music]
when i walk into skid row
i'm overwhelmed with guilt and shame
that a place like skid row
exists
in walking distance of one of the
greatest concert halls in the world
[Music]
for the people who experience chronic
homelessness music is not a form of
entertainment it's a lifeline
and when we make music in skid row it's
not about doing something for the
homeless
it's about understanding our neighbor
[Music]
making music at walt disney concert hall
with the la philharmonic is sacred to me
i get to sit with
some of the greatest musicians in the
country
and present something transcendent
to an audience
almost like i'm putting something on a
pedestal
[Music]
and making music in skid row
is actually about taking that product
off the pedestal
street symphony is an initiative that
brings live musical performances
teaching artistry and storytelling
to people who are impacted by
homelessness and incarceration in la
county
it's comprised of some of the greatest
musicians living and working in los
angeles today and two date has performed
over 500 free concerts in skid row
clinics and shelters as well as in all
five los angeles county jails
it's as much our job to play in the
concert hall as it is to play in skid
row
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i can't talk about the origins of street
symphony without talking about nathaniel
ayers who was the subject of a book in a
movie called the soloist
[Music]
nathaniel was one of the first black men
to ever study at the juilliard school
and in his junior year he was diagnosed
with paranoid schizophrenia and he ended
up living in the second street tunnel
in walking distance of walt disney
concert hall
[Applause]
when i joined the l.a philharmonic i was
asked to become nathaniel's violin
teacher
and then eventually we started having
these lessons in skid row
i started asking the questions of how
many more nathaniel's are out here
because every single person deserves
access to their creative and expressive
life
it's our job to show up to find who
those voices are
[Music]
for people who have experienced pain the
arts are a redemptive connection
back to feeling like their stories and
their lives and their neighborhoods
matter
every street symphony event has a
performative aspect but also a chance
for the audiences to tell their stories
to tell us performers how they've
received that music
in that moment i'm just
a man standing there with a violin and
all i have to offer through that
instrument
is my fullest humanity
[Music]